los primeros votantes del viernes en el
extremo oriente de rusia
horas más tarde iniciaron los sufragios
en siberia y luego en moscú pero también
votos virtuales en siete regiones esa
fue la forma de sufragio del presidente
vladimir putin aislado por un contacto
de kobe 19 lo hizo desde su despacho
donde defendió la modalidad electrónica
de voto ya que es en este sistema de
votación se utiliza en muchos países del
mundo y ya se utilizaba en moscú otras
veces escribir los comicios han sido
cuestionados por la comunidad
internacional y la oposición aliados del
opositor alexéi navalni han sido
excluidos de las elecciones ante esto
han pedido el voto para el partido
comunista con el objetivo de dañar al
partido gobernante rusia unida
a las elecciones sin oposición son un
crimen de la comisión electoral central
han sacado a los candidatos de navalny
este viernes la indignación en la
oposición aumentó después de que rusia
retirarse de google y apple una
aplicación móvil ideada por el entorno
de naval ni en el programa los usuarios
podían ver recomendaciones de voto con
el objetivo de derrotar al partido de
putin una victoria que se antoja
complicada rusia unida lidera las
intenciones de voto y espera a repetir
la mayoría con la que cuenta en la duma
con 334 de 450 legisladores
[Aplausos]